vamos a seguir pensando en cómo los
agentes racionales toman decisiones aquí
nos dicen que sandy dirige un negocio
que sólo vende hamburguesas en un
edificio de su propiedad cada mes venden
5000 hamburguesas a 50 pesos por
hamburguesa gasta 20 pesos por
hamburguesa en insumos como pan carne
lechuga etcétera también paga a migueli
a raúl 25 mil pesos al mes a cada uno
por trabajar en el restaurante
finalmente los costos fijos cuestan 5
mil pesos por mes
sandy trabaja de tiempo completo en el
restaurante y se queda con las ganancias
contables cuál es la ganancia contable
del negocio 2 en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo muy bien vamos a pensar en
esto juntos pensemos en esto en los
términos de los tipos de costos de los
que hablamos en el pasado de modo que
cuando pensamos en ganancias y aquí
podríamos pensar en una empresa aunque
es propiedad de sandy la ganancia para
una empresa que hace negocios es su
ingreso así que los ingresos totales que
ella recauda todo lo que haremos será
mensual
así que sus ingresos totales serán la
cantidad multiplicada por el precio por
lo que serán 5000 hamburguesas a 50
pesos por hamburguesa eso es igual a 250
mil pesos una vez más todo esto es
mensual y podemos ver esto como una
ganancia total que su empresa que su
negocio está obteniendo ahora pensemos
en los costos
en primer lugar pensemos en el costo de
los insumos a menudo se hace referencia
a los costos de los productos vendidos
pero solo escribiré los insumos aquí
entonces los costos y vamos a poner
insumos insumos serían 5000 hamburguesas
x 20 pesos por hamburguesa el costo es
de 100 mil pesos luego tiene el costo de
sus empleados lo voy a abreviar a que es
igual esto bueno ella tiene dos personas
a 25 mil pesos por mes de cada una así
que serán 50 mil pesos dos veces 25 mil
es igual a 50 mil y por último pero no
menos importante tiene sus costos fijos
así que los costos fijos
a nacer de 5 mil pesos al mes de modo
que a partir de esto podemos calcular la
ganancia contable
la ganancia contable es igual a 250000
menos 155 mil es igual a 95 mil pesos al
mes ella se queda con todo esto parece
que es una buena cantidad de dinero ella
está ganando siete cifras al año son
siete cifras al año pero la pregunta es
es racional para ella hacer esto bueno
algunos de ustedes pueden estar pensando
correctamente para determinar si es
racional para ella continuar con ese
negocio tenemos que saber cuáles son los
costos implícitos así que solo hemos
analizado los costos explícitos y el más
importante de los costos implícitos es
el costo de oportunidad y para tener en
cuenta esto tenemos que saber bueno si
no estuviera manejando este negocio de
hamburguesas tal vez podría haber
alquilado su edificio y saber lo que
podría hacer con su tiempo si no
estuviera trabajando en el negocio de
tiempo completo de modo que necesitamos
un poco más de información veamos si
podemos conseguir eso
ahora nos dicen que sandy podría
alquilar su edificio por 50 mil pesos al
mes y también podría ganar 60 mil pesos
al mes como contadora con base en esto
cuál es la ganancia económica de su
negocio así que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo bueno una manera de
pensar en esto es comenzar con nuestra
ganancia contable y luego restar todos
los costos implícitos y especialmente
estos costos de oportunidad que tenemos
aquí por lo tanto su costo de
oportunidad los costos de oportunidad
son mensuales bueno si ella no tuviera
este negocio podría alquilar su edificio
por 50 mil pesos al mes y luego si no
trabajara de tiempo completo podría
ganar 60 mil pesos al mes como contador
a 60 mil pesos por aquí así que su costo
de oportunidad es igual a 110 mil pesos
ahora su ganancia económica sería sus
ingresos totales menos sus costos
explícitos menos sus costos implícitos
su ganancia económica es igual
podríamos comenzar con los 95 mil pesos
y restar los 110 mil pesos es igual a
menos 15 mil pesos es importante darse
cuenta de que debido a que la ganancia
económica siempre toma en cuenta los
costos explícitos y luego otros costos
implícitos potenciales como los costos
de oportunidad la ganancia económica
nunca será más grande que la ganancia
contable y suponiendo que hay algunos
costos implícitos siempre será menor que
la ganancia contable entonces con base
en todo lo que hemos explorado es
racional que sandy continúe con su
negocio de hamburguesas bueno según la
información que nos han dado no parece
racional que continúe administrando su
negocio de hamburguesas ella obtiene 95
mil pesos en ganancias contables del
negocio pero está dejando de ganar 110
mil pesos en el costo de oportunidad por
dejar de hacer la otra actividad y eso
es lo que hace que su ganancia económica
sea negativa esto no es racional
ahora si tuviéramos más información tal
vez ella o de hacer contadora tal vez
hay un beneficio oculto para ella
trabajando en el negocio de la
hamburguesas tiene más flexibilidad con
su tiempo le gusta trabajar por cuenta
propia y no tiene que escuchar a su jefe
decirle lo que tiene que hacer si ese
fuera el caso entonces cambiarían
algunos de los cálculos porque habría un
beneficio adicional de que ella maneje
su negocio de hamburguesas pero no lo
sabemos y según la información que
tenemos no parece racional que ella
continúe hasta el próximo vídeo